teachers union boss Randy Weingarten
facing a new round of backlash after she
admitted remote learning didn't work she
tweeted what we have seen in public
education is that technology can't
replace teachers remote education didn't
work in part because you have to have
relationships you have to build trust
but critics were quick to point out that
teachers unions pushed to keep kids out
of the classroom through the early days
of the pandemic listen to what she said
in 2020.
but if the authorities don't protect the
safety and health of those we represent
and those we serve nothing is off the
table
that advocacy or protests negotiations
grievances or lawsuits or if necessary
as a last resort safety strikes
Jesse I want to come to you first
I was surprised that she walked into
this one with this Suite were you
surprised I'm surprised she made it back
from Ukraine really glad you're back in
this country
um she went to Ukraine twice did you
know that last year yeah so funny
so she helped all the schools shut down
and then when parents got mad
she said that they needed to get paid
billions of dollars
and then they needed to jump the line to
get vaccinated and then they still
stayed home and when they finally got
back she said yeah yeah I did a great
job we went and looked at the money that
she squeezed out of Chicago for instance
is like two billion dollars guess what
the teachers spent it on no they did not
spend it on health and safety they spent
it on salaries they took half the money
and they gave bonuses to the teachers
you know how many laptops they bought
with the money five thousand do you know
how many kids are in the Chicago Public
School District hundreds of thousands
what did I say all last year they're
going to steal the money they're going
to embezzle the money they did and they
did it in broad daylight so if you're a
teacher you know Well Done Randy is the
best she gets you paid yeah
um Dana we've seen huge spikes and kids
going to private school Charter Schools
homeschooling is doubled do you think
that this trend is going to continue oh
yes I do and it's partly because of what
happened with kovid and also just not
only covet in terms of schools being
locked down but parents then actually
being able to see and hear what was
happening on Zoom school knowing what
knowing that it wasn't working but also
saying whoa what are they teaching my
children so if there are options people
are looking for options I don't
understand why she tweeted this so it's
either because she just tweets randomly
she had remember in 2022 her tweet about
the Brittany Greiner release and oh the
aside about Paul whalen's is still being
stuck over there was the worst unforced
error of Twitter of 2022. now you have
this you have to ask yourself so why
what's going on do they realize that
they're having this problem is she
thinking that she's about to get blamed
for all these students leaving the
public schools maybe that's it but the
other thing is she acts like nobody
remembers what we actually know in
emails between Randy Weingarten and the
CDC in which they were asking the Biden
Administration to make sure that school
stays closed and that was that was why
Rachelle wolinski the head of the CDC
who's standing in front of the CDC
Banner saying schools should be open and
the White House Press Secretary says she
was speaking in her personal capacity
why because Randy weingartner was
sending these tweets to CDC or emails to
the CDC saying keep schools closed so I
don't know whether this is a little bit
of cya or just not believing that we can
actually understand with our own eyes
and ears what we saw what does a stand
for in that which one a
um ours Greg
you know how much Jessica that I despise
children with every fiber of my being I
think they're expressing about my own
child I I I hate your child as much as I
hate all children but even I wouldn't be
as punitive as this diabolical hag has
been she is like China it is time this
relationship calls for a DEC coupling
it's time for the teachers and the
parents I don't even I don't blame the
teachers for Randy Weingarten it's a
teacher's Union we have to probably make
it clear that we don't want to smear
everybody for the actions of this Union
after all it's called the teachers union
they're putting teachers first but
parents and kids last and they're
actually put in the union before
everybody else so I think it's time you
know and I keep asking my I said this is
there what happened to the PTA I should
have Googled that that's still around
are they still in general isn't that a
interesting point they're still around
well where the hell were they during
covid why weren't they out like I don't
know I didn't I didn't see anything
about the PTA doing anything important
and I am pretty knowledgeable on time
but I I think I said this last week and
uh which is I think
that do what there should be like a
class action suit for damages to to for
the children during lockdown and they
should name her as the what do you call
it the plaintiff no the defendant
I would call it acting like a trial
lawyer I am I am I would call it
reparations but I know that like people
would who don't understand that word
would be offended by it but these kids
need reparations yeah Katie uh Randy
Weingarten held kids and their parents
and not just all kids but the most
vulnerable kids in our country hostage
for years while she extorted the
American taxpayer for millions of
dollars which they then did not use to
further the education of those children
whose lives have been changed forever
study after study has proved it we knew
it at the beginning Rand Paul brought it
up early in May 2020. um she is
panicking it is the CIA because
Governors all over the country are
adopting policies and legislation that
defunds the systems that enable her
behavior and funds students that their
parents have choices about where they
get educated by whom they get educated
as well all right hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary carry
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on Fox you
can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now